let's do some more matrix multiplication
example because I think it is all about
seeing as many examples as possible so
let's do what may seem to be a more
difficult problem and it might not be
even clear that we can multiply these
matrices and maybe that's the first
thing we should think about so let's say
I wanted to multiply the matrix I'll do
it relatively small so we don't run out
of space 3 1 2 minus 2 0 5 let's say I
want to multiply that times the matrix
minus 1 0 2 3 5 5 I'm just making up
these numbers so the first thing you
might be wondering is well can I even
multiply these matrices because you know
from the first video we did on matrices
and you can't add these two matrices
you know they this term corresponds to
this one this one corresponds to this
one but there's this term corresponds to
nothing over here so you couldn't add or
subtract these matrices so the question
is can I multiply these matrices well
what did we learn about multiplying
matrices we learned we know that for
example if you know this is going to
result in some matrix however we don't
know even what the dimensions are yet
until we work through this example
although there's a quick way of figuring
it out so this first term here the upper
left term where does it get its row
information from and where does it get
its column information from well gets
its row information from here so it's
essentially this row times which column
times this column right and we can
actually take the dot product of this
row vector and this column vector
because they have the same length this
is a column vector but it has a length
of three right it's a three by one but
it's it has three elements in it and
this is a one by three row vector but it
also has three elements in it so we
actually can take the dot product or we
can multiply these two and similarly we
can multiply this
times this whole thing to get this term
right here and we can multiply this
thing times this thing to get this term
and then this thing times that term to
get that term so it actually turns out
that you can so what what kind of a
matrix is this let's call that this is
this is matrix let me switch an
arbitrary comb so this is matrix a and
what are its dimensions its dimensions
are it has two rows 1 2 & 3 columns 1 2
3 so it's a 2 by 3 matrix it's a 2 by 3
matrix and we're multiplying it times B
B and what are B's dimensions well has 3
rows 1 2 3 so it's a 3 by and how many
columns does it have 1 2 2 matrix so it
turns out that we can multiply two
matrices if kind of you can kind of say
that the number if on the first matrix
the number of columns is equal to the
number of rows in the second Matrix so
here 2 by 3 times 3 by 2 we can multiply
for example we could have multiplied you
know if this is matrix C I don't know if
I take so much time to keep bolding
these things and I don't care what how
many rows it has it can have n rows n
times a columns I can multiply it times
matrix D as long as matrix D has a rows
as long as you can kind of say these two
inner numbers are the same right this 3
is the same as 3 and why does that
matter what where's the logic because
this row will have 3 elements because
there are 3 columns and each column
vector here will have 3 elements because
there are 3 rows that's the intuition
comes from but if you do it real quick
you say 2 by 3 3 by 2 this number is
equal to that number I can multiply so
let me clear up some space and let's do
the multiplication let's do some
multiplication let's do some what I'm
debating where that where I should do it
actually I think I should do it down
here maybe because I'll have more space
so let me do it down there and after
anything else so let me get some space
ready okay this is will take up a lot of
space so to get this row-one column-one
element what do I do I multiply this
vector times this factor I take the dot
product right so 3 times negative 1 I'm
just gonna write it all out 3 times
minus 1 plus 1 times 0 plus 1 times 0
plus 2 times 2 which is I'll just write
it 2 times 2 there we got the first term
so the second term here what I'm going
to do I'm going to multiply that vector
times that row vector times this column
vector and I think you're getting the
hang of this and it's it's really the
hardest part about this it's just not
you know staying focused and not making
a careless mistake and not getting
confused with rows and columns and all
that so it's a bit of it you know just
kind of set this blood to your brain but
it's not that hard I think so what do we
do we multiply this row vector times
this column vector to get row 1 column 2
right because it's row this row Row 1
column 2 3 times 3 so it's 3 times 3
plus 1 times 5 plus 1 times 5 plus 2
times 5 all right we're just kind of
multiplying the corresponding terms
although you know this the third times
on the third term the second term times
the second term the first term times the
first term although you know in this
case they're kind of going down in this
case they're going left and right and we
add them all up ok so now we're in the
second row and we get our row
information from the first vector and
let me do a red that I never use because
I think it's kind of tacky but this red
right here so I'm going to multiply this
row vector times this column vector so
it's minus 2 minus 2 times minus 1 times
minus 1 plus 0 times 0 0 times 0 plus 5
times 2 plus 5 times 2 we're almost done
let me see I don't like this color at
all and now we're going to multiply this
row because we're in this bottom row
we're in row 2 column 2 row 2 column 2
so it's minus 2 times 3 minus 2
times three plus zero times five plus
zero times five plus five times five
that's five times five and then if we
simplify it let's see this is let's see
minus three plus zero plus four so this
is if I my math is correct this
simplifies to 1 9 plus 5 is 14 plus 10
is 24 this is 124 and then minus two x
plus 1 is 2 plus 10 this is 12 right
this 12 and then minus 2 times the 3
it's 6 minus 6 plus 10 this is 0 so
minus 6 plus 10 is 4 so that's
interesting when I multiplied a 2x3
vector times a 3 by 2 vector what did I
get I got a 2 by 2 a dasari matrix a 3 a
2 by 3 matrix 2 by 3 times 3 by 2 matrix
I got a 2 by 2 matrix and where do you
see a 2 by 2 well it's kind of like this
got multiplied with this and we have
left over as a 2 by 2 matrix so in
general well actually before I go into
the general let me ask you a question
could I have multiplied the matrices the
other way could I have multiplied so
this is this right here that is a times
B or you can sometimes write just a B
and we'd bolt it all up so we know it's
matrices so couldn't we have multiplied
B times a let me clear this down here
and let's try let's see if we can
multiply B times a and I think you can
already suspect that since I'm asking
the question maybe you cannot let's see
clear up some space so let's try to go
let's try to do it the other way around
let's try to multiply B times a so B is
minus 1 0 2 3 5 5 & a is I'm just
switching the order 3 1 2 minus 2 0 5
and I tend to put brackets around my
matrices some people have these big
parentheses it's just all notation
there's nothing particular about
notation so let's see if you can
multiply these so we we learned that you
get the row information from the first
matrix and the column information from
the second one so this term in theory
should be that row times what times well
actually it turns out that you can't
multiply them either because why because
this is a this is a 3 by 2 and this is a
2 by 3 all right so we're going to take
that row times what times this column to
get the first term right so what is it
going to be it's going to be minus 1 so
I actually thought I was doing a counter
example but actually because this 2 is
the same as this or when you switch the
road this is the same as this it
actually it actually you can multiply
them so I wanted to do a counter example
but hey let's just work through this
because it never hurts to see another
example and as you can see I do this on
the fly so let's do this and actually
I'll just says ahead of time how large
will this matrix be what this is
interesting
it's actually going to be a 3 by 3
matrix so this is going to be a much
bigger matrix so let's let's work it all
out and maybe you want to pause it and
try it yourself so it's this row times
this column so minus 1 times 3 it's
minus 3 so this is minus 3 times 3 times
minus 2 is minus 6 and then it's going
to be this row times this column so it's
minus 1 times 1 plus 3 times 0 so that's
just minus 1 right because it's 3 times
0 0 and then so that's that was that one
then the middle one and now if the row 1
column 3 so Row 1 column 3 so it's that
row times this column you tell this is
often better done by a computer minus 1
times 2 is minus 2 plus 15 3 times 5 so
minus 2 plus is 13 let's keep going so
now we're going to take this is I'm
sweating this is so computationally
intensive we take this row times each of
these columns and actually were going to
learn later there's multiple ways of
actually kind of thinking about how this
multiplication happens or even multiple
ways computer but this is the
traditional way so this row times each
of these columns
so 0 5 so 0 times 3 plus 5 times minus 2
that's minus 10 if 0 times 1 plus 5
times 0 that's easy that's 0 0 times 2
plus 5 times 5 that's 25 almost there
almost done now we're going to take this
row and multiply it times each of these
columns so 2 times 3 plus so that's 6
plus minus 10 so that's minus 4 right 2
times 3 plus 5 times minus 2 yeah that's
minus 4 6 - right you have 2 times 1
plus 5 times 0 that's 2 then you have 2
times 2 plus 5 times 5 so 4 plus 25 29
and of course that first term minus 3
minus 6 so this is this is minus 9 so
there you have it we multiply the 3 by 2
matrix times a 2 by 3 matrix and we got
a 3 by 3 matrix and where did that 3 by
3 came from because these are this this
3 is the number of rows in the first
matrix and this 3 is the number of
columns in the second Matrix which makes
sense because we got our row information
from the first matrix and our column
information from the second Matrix now
let me actually show you an example that
you cannot multiply so what if I wanted
to multiply a let me do a very simple
example what if I wanted to multiply the
matrix 2 1 and really this is all this
is is a row vector and let's say that I
wanted to multiply this times I want to
multiply this times I don't know so this
is this is a 2 by 1 so then let me say
let me say I wanted to multiply this
times so let me think of something
1 2 3
one two three four five six now can I
multiply this well what do we and this
is what this is a three by two matrix
can I multiply these two matrices well
what do we have to do we get our row
information from here and our column
information from your outside this isn't
this isn't two by one this is one row
two columns this is a one by two
all right that's a one by two matrix so
can you multiply the 1 by 2 times the 3
by 2 matrix so we got our row
information from here so we essentially
have to multiply this times this column
to get our first element then this times
this column to get our second element
and I don't know what happens from there
but let me well can we multiply I can
just the way we've defined our
multiplication or the dot product can we
multiply let's see we do 2 times 1 plus
1 times 2 but then we don't have
anything to do with the 3 so the way
that we've defined matrix multiplication
you cannot multiply these two matrices
and you didn't have to go through that
exercise you could have looked at the
dimensions one by two and this is a 3 by
2 this 2 is not equal to this 3 the
number of columns in the first are not
equal to the number of rows in the
second so you cannot multiply those two
matrices so that's something interesting
to think about and and there are
actually examples and it's it's a good
exercise for you to think about it where
you can multiply them you know where you
can multiply a times B but you can't
multiply B times a so and I want you to
think about examples where that happens
but anyway I'm pushing 15 minutes and I
will see you in the next video